retourner.
Reportage et ensuite on parle
au directeur des producteurs de
porc du Québec.
- Ils ont tout... icitte, là,
cet exemple-là, ils ont tous
21 pieds carrés par truie.
Ils ont de la place rien
qu'en masse. Regardez, là,
là-bas, il y a pas personne.
Mais à la minute qu'ils ont
la chance, ils se collent
unes sur les autres.
- C'est une tetete révolution
qui vient de se dérouler dans
la porcherie de Mathieu Pilote.
Propriétaire de la ferme
familiale depuis plus de 5 ans,
le producteur de Charlevoix
a réaménagé ses installations
pour se conformer aux nouvelles
normes de bien-être animal.
- Avant, on avait les truies
qui étaient toutes en logettes,
toute leur vie. Elles avaient
accès à l'eau, la nourriture,
mais elles avaient un petit
espace d'environ 14 pieds carrés
pour s'exprimer toleleleur vie.
- À compter de 2029,
les producteurs de porcs
du Canada devront élever
leurs truies en groupe,
comme ici.
(petits grognements)
C'est ce que prévoit une mise
à jour du Code de pratique
de l'industrie, dont l'adhésion
est en principe facultative.
Mais les producteurs
qui ne se conforment pas
seront incapables incapables
de vendre leurs cochons
dans les abattoirs.
MATHIEU PILOTE,
copropriétaire, Ferme Pilote
- Nos transformateurs
nous disent qu'il y a
de plus en plus de marchés
qui vont... ils exigent
des truies en groupe
pour accepter les animaux,
pour accepter la viande.
C'était comme ça, comme vous
le voyez là, partout.
- Mais ce ne sera pas
la fin des cages de gestation
pour autant.
Après leur insémination,
les truies pourront passer
jusqu'à cinq semaines dans des
stalles, une façon de réduire
les risques de fausses couches.
- Une gestation, ça dure
115 jours. Ça veut dire
que les premiers 35 jours
au Canada, c'est encore légal,
puis c'est à ces normes-là
que j'ai répondu, de les laisser
en stalles individuelles.
Ensuite de ça, il faut qu'elle
soit en groupe pour la majeure
partie de sa gestation,
allé jusqu'à 115 jours.
Ensuite de ça, elle retourne
dans une stalle individu
pour mettre bas.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Avec les nouvelles normes,
les truies seront confinées
dans des cages pendant
la moitié de leur vie environ,
plutôt qu'en totalité.
Selon ce spécialiste
du comportement des porcs
au Centre de recherche fédéral
de Sherbrooke, il nnnnnn
doute : l'élevage en groupe
est de loin préférable
pour le bien-être des animaux.
NICOLAS DEVILLERS, cherch. en
comport.êêêêêêtre du porc
- Les truies peuvent se
déplacer, peuvent se retourner,
donc ça leur permet d'avoir
cette liberté de mouvement
memememememer les comportements
aussi plus facilement que
d'être pris dans un espace
qui est très exigü. Les porcs,oi
cherchent le contact des autres,
donc ça leur permet d'avoir des
contacts sociaux entre elles.
- Je vous dirais que les animaux
sont plus calmes, un peu...
un peu moins anxieux.
Il y a un envers à la médaille,
parce que des animaux
qui socialisent, bien, il y a
une hiérarchie qui s'établit,
il y a plus de bagarres.
- Tout producteur va dire :
la transition entre un modèle
et l'autre a un très grand lotix
ne s'adaptent pas au...
à ce modèle-là. Donc,
ça va demander un peu plus
de changements d'animaux,
des nouveaux animaux,
des plus jeunes qui vont
être capables de s'adapter
au nouvel environnement.
♪ ♪ ♪
- On estime que 55 %
des quelques 290 000 truies
du Québec sont déjà élevées
en groupe.
Mathieu Pilote a investi
m m m m m m m moderniser
ses bâtiments et installer
un système automatisé pour
s'assurer que toutes les truies
ont accès àntntntntntntntntité
de nourriture. Il a aussi dû
réduire son cheptel, sans quoi
un agrandissement aurait été
nécessai
- On avait une capacitérurururut
comprendre qu'on a été obligé
de descendre à 288 truies
pour être capable de le faire
à l'intérieur des murs.
Si j'avais pas mis
d'automatisation puis de gestion
de troupeau en plus pour essayer
d'aller chercher une certaine
rentabilité, mettre les truies
en parc, en soi, c'est zéro
rentable.
- Les producteurs n'ont pas
le choix, la pression est
de plus en plus forte.
Elle vient des acheteurs et
des consommateurs et aussi des
groupes de défense des animaux.
Selon eux, les nouve
ne vont pas assez loin
et elles auraient dû entrer
en vigueur l'année prochaine,
tel que prévu
Me SOPHIE GAILLARD, dg par
intérim, SPCA de Montréal
- En réponse aux pressions
de l'i e e e e e e e e e encore
prolongé jusqu'en 2029.
À notre avis, c'est beaucoup
trop long et il ya aussi trop
d'exceptions qui sont prévues,m,
parce que justement, on peut
continuer à garder les truies
dans ces cages-là 35 jours.
- Des normes similaires à celles
qui seront appliquées au Canada
dans six ans sont déjà en place
depuis 2013 au sein de l'Union
européenne et certains pays
ont agi bien avant. En Suède,
par exemple, l'utilisation
de cages est complètement bannie
depuis 1988. Dix États
américains l'ont aussi fait
ou sont en voie de le faire.
- Dix États comme, par exemple,
la Californie, l'Ariziona, etc.
C'est sûr que ce sont pas
les États qui sont les plus gros
producteurs
dire que l'Iowa, par exemple,
ou encore le Minnesota,
qui sont des États qui
produicscscscscscscscscscscs,
la Caroline du Nord, ont pas mis
en place des législations comme
celles-là. Donc dans ces États-
cacacacacacacacacacacages sont
toujours autorisées.
- Les producteurs d'ici
craignent donc que du porc
américain soit vendu à mei
prix sur le marché canadien.
- Si on a un coût de production
qui est plus élevé puis que
les consommateurs ne sont pas
prêts à le paye
choisissent plutôt la viande
d'un autre pays, bien,
on rend service à personne.
- Se faire imposer des normes
qu'on dit plus humaines
par des humains qui n'ont jamais
travaillé avec les animaux,adad.
- Et ce n'est sans doute pas
le dernier changement qui seraa.
La castration des porcelets,
qui est pratiquée pour que
la viande ait meilleur goût,
restera permise au Canada.
Même chose pour la caudectomie,
c'est-à-dire couper la queue
des cochons pour éviter
qu'ils mordillent celle
du voisin et qu'elle s'infecte.
Une analgésie est requise
pour les deux procédures,
mais pas d'anesthésie.
- Ça a été documenté
scientifiquement que c'est très
do.............
Alors, la seule façon de
supprimer totalement, c'est de
pas castrer, et c'est ce qui se.
- Pour Mathieu Pilote,
le passage à l'élevage de groupe
a été difficile.
- Je vous aurais parlé après
deux mois, je vous aurais dit
que ça va très mal, mais
on s'habitue au système, puis
les animaux, on a enlevé les
animaux qui étaient plus vieux,
puis là, finalement ça va mieux.
- Il espère que les
consommateurs vont comprendree r
le bien-être de leurs animaux,
mais qu'ils veulent aussi être
capables de gagner leur vi